final project for the machine learning
course at Georgetown
and I'm talking about brain tumor
subtype exploration for candidate
biomarkers
I chose this project because I'm
interested in the use of machine
learning Effectiveness clinically in
this original research project
specifically the authors achieved in
90.1 accuracy with a random forest model
of categorizing five different cancer
brain cancer
subtypes and my goal is to matric seed
that accuracy and evaluate how the model
can distinguish between different types
of brain cancer and also if we can use
that to distinguish between Cancer
versus the same model to distinguish
between Cancer versus normal tumor types
and so that is a challenge that I looked
at solving is classifying those five
pediatric cancer brain cancer subtypes
from gene expression levels that were
captured from the original authors of
the study and they classify those cancer
and non-cancer samples
and then if we could successfully
distinguish between the different cancer
subtypes identify the significant genes
so that we can expand future work
to use those genes as biomarkers for
immunotherapy
and so the hypothesis is that the
accuracy will be able to be matched
there's already an existing random
forest model of this data with a 90
accuracy rate so the goal is to meet
that however I do not 100 sure if we can
distinguish between Cancer versus
non-cancer or just between the different
types of
brain cancer that we're looking at so
we'll see what happens with the
with the broader application there but
then I do believe that
with distinguishing between the
different subtypes of brain cancer will
be able to identify the common
common genes among the campers that get
cancers that can be used as candidate
biomarkers moving forward
and so so a little bit of background on
this brain tumors are where the leading
cause of death for Childhood Cancer in
2013 and that was the impetus for the
original author's work where
they collected different brain tumor
samples from different children and
recognize that they have different Amino
phenotypes and so the goal of the
original study was to try to treat those
different brain cancers by targeting the
amino phenotypes and the the data was
aggregated and a random forest model was
applied to it that found a 91 accuracy
and that came from a different source so
the goal here is to reproduce those
results that were originally found in
that
and so I did was I first explored the
data using PCA and heat maps to try to
get an overall big picture of what the
data looked like and with the PCA I had
found that there wasn't any clear
distinguishable groupings with the
different brain samples or within the
different non-tumor normal samples so it
didn't look very promising initially so
I used lazy predict to try to run
a large number of
classification models all at once and
get an estimate of which would be able
to work with the data most successfully
and lazy predict actually predicted
random force to be one of the top five
models so I ended up proceeding with
that classification method and from
there I looked at which features were
deemed significant in the random Forest
classification
and here's an example of the confusion
Matrix that came from using the random
Forest data and we ultimately got a 97.4
percent accuracy we can see the only
misclassified
cancer subtype there's the one pilotic
astrocytoma
however that also had the second fewest
number of test samples after using a
test transplant of 30 of the test data
and so it's not too surprising that the
results are off but it's very
beneficial to see that the results were
so successful throughout for each brain
type brain cancer type and for the
normal non-tuber examples
and so the other part of the project
that I did was I took I looked at all
the combined data so the five different
cancer subtypes versus normal I grouped
all the cancer subtypes into one cancer
type and compare those to normal and
they did each individual cancer versus
the non-termware normal samples to the
geoblastomas the medulla blastomas the
pilotic astrocytomas and the epidomals
versus normal samples and looked at each
feature that was deemed significant in
the random Forest classification and
mapped those back to which genes that
are representative based on the gene
expression levels that were used
and then look into the functions of
those genes or the proteins that they
coded for to see if there was anything
in common and it kind of appeared that
there is nothing
there was no overlap between any of the
individual brain cancers or cancer as a
whole
so that kind of is indicative
that these different brain cancers or
subtypes do have the different Amino
phenotype those was confirmed in the
original literature that looked into
this data seeking to find the candidate
biomarkers so this investigation kind of
validated those results and shows that
we can potentially Target these genes
moving forward for immunotherapies
and that is the big takeaway is that
there is potential for Pediatric brain
cancer subtype biomarkers looking at
these genes that were deem significant
in distinguishing each different brain
cancer subtype from one another
and we were able to do that with the
random forest model that had a 97.4
accuracy and that accuracy was also
applied when distinguishing cancer
versus normal in the broader
categorization and so moving forward
future work can be done exploring these
genes and the proteins that they code
for for the potential for biomarker
targets for immunotherapy and the
viability of those tools throughout
those genes to be used in tooling moving
forward for treatment options
thank you